let's talk about other video game
predictions for e3
uh we've got a list here and it
basically says what can we
reasonably expect and i'm just gonna say
reasonably expect let's not make this
boring yeah there are some
let's get let's let's get the reasonable
stuff out of the way
are you dissing my my copy my what i
wrote down
no what i'm saying is like let's get the
reasonable stuff out of the way
so then we can we can get to the stuff
that's like this is
kooky behavior that you are talking
about sure sure
so we've got a list here we've got halo
infinite that's a big one
um almost a dead cert right i mean it's
got to be
right yeah i mean 20th 20th year of halo
23 of xbox
we know there's going to be an xbox
bethesda showcase easy
chalk that one up so and their game's
out this year isn't it
is that this year unfortunately yeah
summer isn't it
yeah september i don't think they're
going to push it again yeah
um my question is there is a joint
bethesda
and microsoft con uh conference are we
wading into the star
field discourse no no no what i'm saying
is there's a joint
um conference happening between bethesda
and microsoft what bethesda character
appears
as a uh a i don't know downloadable skin
in halo infinite
is that overkin or is it todd howard
everyone gets to submit one
yes even who is your submission for a
bethesda character in halo as a new
master chief skin
oh man um you know
i don't know um i kind of want to
download tomorrow as this game um
tam would you would you be a student in
haiti i would
so there's there in the original trailer
there's master chief on that
i think he's in a pelican he's on some
sort of ship and there's his pilot who
is very upset about everything
who is basically a face swap of me
like i saw it and i was like that looks
like me and then i got like seven
messages being like are you in halo
and i was like i would love that if it
can't be tam then it's gonna be dog meat
we're gonna we gotta dog meat has to
make an appearance
that would be incredible like like
holographic dog meat cortana's gone but
it's just dog meat now
but he just appears and every time chief
asks him a question he just box and then
leaves a very dramatic part by the way
let's get some very good feel emotion
every bark
lucy who's your pick todd howard todd
howard
okay i mean actually it's i mean if they
did do some kind of crossover
it might be colt and juliana because
death loop is out this year
um but no my heart my heart says todd
john luke so todd howard but not in the
way you think
it's not like you know mass troop takes
his helmet off and it's todd howard
it's uh todd howard in his like premiere
e3 jacket
his his his dream but with the master of
which
we have the article we know where he got
that jacket exactly
yeah but you were going way different
that you're you're for those of you who
are not watching but listening you just
john look just made this like uh jumping
out of an airplane and about to
parachute in motion
piloting in with the e3 banner so it's
todd howard but uh he's a kind of like
kill streak but it's like a orbital
bombardment but every missile is todd
howard
[Laughter]
say like in the bombardment but it was
just copies of skyrim
absolutely bodied by copies of skyrim
all right let's carry on through these
uh reasonably expect games
suicide squad and gotham knights i mean
i i think gotham might be a suicide
squad
probably not the suicide's quite the
movie out this year
i don't think so it could be a good
question i can't remember
if if the movie's out then
maybe but also don't forget the dc
fandoms coming back
which is where they showed off this last
year if i'm right and thinking so maybe
they'll kind of like
tease it tease it um but yeah in terms
of like whatever pc is now owned by
discovery
i can't keep track anymore because i
know that the
didn't didn't they break the studios up
a little bit as well
i cannot tell you i it's so confusing
but uh
i don't think it's going to have a major
impact on the way they show off games
but yeah i think you're right gotham
knights is the one that they'll probably
show off the most
which honestly i'm i'm good with like
show me i like it when
when there's a focus in a press
conference i know about you folks but
like
when it's here's our press conference
it's got 30 games in it i'm like oh
please you want you want to i mean i
think you want to give them
kind of a bit more time to shine
especially when we've already seen
gameplay of gotham knights like we've
got quite a meaty look at it last year
yeah so unless they're gonna do that
same thing with suicide squad
which i would also be down for because
that game like we only just saw a
sort of pre-rendered trailer um yeah
gamepl
i think it is it might be yeah i
wouldn't be surprised
uh i think it is it was shown on p uh
shown and announced as a ps5 thing
um but i wouldn't be surprised if it
shows up some other places because
i mean square like doing their own
little things now yeah and like
the last few final fantasies have all
been um
multi-plat so um
wait final fantasy 7 wasn't there no
seven wasn't wasn't
the other ones before that have been so
i wouldn't be surprised if it shows up
in some regard there
i think seven's locked seven's the one
that sony were like
never you don't wanna go anywhere else
this belongs the top we made you yeah
it's like like the deal with the devil
but for like you know
one day i will come for you like that's
how it is and it's always that like sony
owns
owns the final fantasy 7 brand into a
degree
um but i'm excited to see that game
especially given the team working on it
being and the folks behind it being the
ziv team
um you know i want to be i want to be i
want to be in a world where michael him
cries
non-stop about the game he's playing and
that is seemingly what final fantasy 17
16 is gonna be
also i don't know about you but i think
it's time to
hit reset on the numbers on the final
fantasy because
we're at 16 now yeah i just kind of just
want them to go to that weird like
um xbox way of doing it let's just
change it to
a numeral this year let's make it like
you know final fantasy xxelc
and then like the after that we'll make
it xbox square and then
after that we'll just make it like where
it's a color it's just final fantasy
7 blue i mean i mean
they kind of already did yeah they kind
of do that yeah i think like they should
be borrowing from like the the
mmo it's like final fantasy end walker
like okay yeah i can get better yeah
yeah final fantasy
a realm reborn isn't that fair enough
we've got a we've got one here which is
dragon age four and then next to it is
in all caps please buy or wear
i think i can guess who wrote that
surprisingly not me
that was actually me cause cause
i need i need that dragon age for like i
need
you know uh bioware's got a lot of good
good momentum right now with the the
legendary edition
uh but you know those are those are
still old games i need new bioware i
need
i need i need them to show that they
still got the magic
and uh i'm i think there's a lot riding
on on dragon age four
um also i just i personally i love
dragon age so much
uh like uh origins is one of my favorite
games of all time and
i really love too i'm like a defender of
two um one of those people and then i
also quite like inquisition so i just i
need to see
i need to see that game uh because
because bioware loves to
announce games years in advance and
never show it
and they've been they've been teasing
for for a while so it's time
it's time to show that game off yeah i
mean they've been they've been holding
stuff a lot for the kiwis
um at the end of the year so maybe
i don't know maybe this time they'll be
like okay we're riding off the high of
legendary edition
it's time let's get this out there so
i'm down
i'd be excited to see dragon age at this
point see this is what we
are going in with they are going to
absolutely debate us with a new like
star wars expansion for for
they're going to bring back uh the old
republic yeah
yeah we
battlefront shield here we go yeah there
we go
um so those are what we can reasonably
expect there's a bunch of other games
that we can reasonably expect because
you know people are already announcing
their presence there and
you can look at the release late now
this is the fun part i want the wild
predictions
everyone gets one wild prediction slot
and
i'm gonna start obviously
i doubt you can even imagine it being
there but i do it every night
every day i think i know what you're
gonna say it's elven ring baby
i was like what are you doing every
night and every day that's a little
weird phrasing
thinking about elden ring oh okay
there's nothing wrong
what do you guys think i was perverted i
mean i'm i am naked when i'm doing it
but you know
at this point it's like they have to
they have to show it i mean i guess they
don't but
like they have they kind of have to my
hope
my hope is that they show it if you ask
me whether i think it will happen
absolutely not like no chance i feel
like that leak happened and then
everyone in that studio went well these
guys we're not going to show them
anything wow
we're going to go back to ground we're
just going back goodbye forever i feel
like miyazaki was like you've hurt me
personally
and now you will all pay uh you will not
hear about alden ring until the day
is delivered to your door so that's my
that's my prediction uh jean-luc what's
your one
wild prediction for e3
wild prediction uh give me more time
okay beyond good and evil too
back from the dead i mean it never
officially died
but i don't i don't know what that game
is
but we finally understand yeah
understand we'll be on good and evil
tours and like
uh what'd you call him joseph
gordon-levitt just
standing next to it being like i'm
working on this too well that was the
thing is that
he was asking people for to put stuff in
with hit record but i didn't understand
what sort of like
if there would be rav share or if there
would be any kind of like monetary
uh compensation for people doing that i
mean i guess like there's not
in stuff like dreams maybe they'll have
taken the dreams approach to how i just
but also i just don't understand how
that game is a beyond good and evil game
because
the original beyond good and evil is
about
taking pictures and occasionally hitting
someone with a stick
like i don't understand what they're
i don't know that's why that's my
prediction the interesting thing will be
like
ubisoft had a recent statement where
they put out they were moving towards
free-to-play
long-term video game model which
i imagine is going to apply to any game
that is currently in development and
oh boy beyond good and evil too looks
like it could very easily be
um turned into a free to play open world
mmo type game but like beyond good and
evil
as a as a name is not a household name
it's not a
tom clancy like i
i don't understand if they were to do
that with something like beyond good
evil doesn't have the brand awareness to
push through i don't think um to put my
biz hat on for a sec but yeah
unfortunately i could see that with what
they've
sort of showed off with it a little bit
um
stephen what's your what's your wild
pick
it's going to be witcher computer
builder simulator and it's just going to
be
all in a top witcher outfit
just building computers and you're going
to get to control the ball
and uh it's going to be it's going to be
a great game to build
learn computer building and uh you know
quench thirst
i'm genuinely into this like this is a
great idea like why has no one because
there is that game where you can build
computers right yeah that's right pc
builder why have they not just hit up
henry cavill i've been like
give us your arms yeah that's it's going
to be a devolver digital uh exclusive
they're going to put it out in all
platforms uh it's gonna have a
playstation skin exclusive
where it's uh it's just gonna be him
just uh with the
the wild eyes and the white hair but
topless for some reason
you've made such a compelling case i'm
moving it from world predictions to
what we can reasonably expect
i love that i would play that jean-luc
what's your uh wild prediction
okay so i think you turned to your
screen as if you'd been typing for the
last 10 minutes and you've got like an
essay ready
no no i will i've been furiously
thinking i
i think i think microsoft's got to go
real bold this year
you know like i think they need to they
need to really throw something out there
so i think
i think they should bring back
they they need to bring back uh steel
battalion
oh that's my guess steel battalion oh
with the controller without the control
oh with the controller 100 okay that's
that's where they're going
uh like i uh honestly i i
i legitimately just like do you think
like i
i need microsoft to just like completely
surprise me
with with something like uh acquiring
capcom
that would be insane i don't i don't
think sony would uh
would let them at this point you know
sony sony's so invested in like
resident evil and like street fighter
they wouldn't let they wouldn't let it
happen
no i think it would be it would be bans
though wouldn't it it would be
it would be a it would be like omega
bands if they came in and we're like
we're buying uh capcom and tony's like
but
wait wasn't there who wasn't there like
rumors a while ago and someone was good
by square enix and
just these like cyclical conversations
of rumors and stuff
so there's always rumors about like uh
you could probably start a rumor saying
ablegamers is gonna acquire from
software and people will be like down
uh any interested in acquiring from
software or any what
if you could acquire any developer what
would you acquire
well i would immediately acquire from
software
and it would be nothing but easy mode
secure
yes i was
literally just waiting for all of you
looking do you have hard mode no that's
not the intent of the original
developers it's all easy
to hear out as someone who is uh who has
played a lot of sakura
and um is somewhat known for playing
from software games
i would be very happy to offer my
services as a brand ambassador for that
move
ah you're in i would stand there be like
i approve this
can't wait awesome so there we have it
those are our predictions
for e3 um i think it's going to be an
exciting evening what you're
kind of like are you excited about e3 um
and
do you reckon it's gonna be as hype as
it has been previously
uh lucy i'm always excited about e3
but i i still feel like it's going to be
a bit of a weird one because
i think the impact of last year
is really going to be properly felt this
year and so
i wonder if you know this isn't the e3
that everyone had planned on
released and announce wise i think we're
still gonna be suffering
for a good few months but i think
there's always reason to be excited
and i think there will still be
surprises and um
people just getting hype about upcoming
stuff so i'm always excited but i think
we're not going to see
e3 return to the form until next year
and it's not it's not because it's you
know digital and we're not in person
it's because
just pandemic in it yeah
see it's interesting lucy said like um
won't return to form till
next year steve do you reckon there
like this do you see this year as like a
make a break moment for
e3 and the esa or do you where like if
it doesn't really pop
off this year people might really start
reconsidering their involvement or do
you reckon
they've got like one or two more
attempts at this i think that
the shows in general um e3's and
15 in particular but also things like
packs they really have to figure out
where they're going to go
in the post-pandemic world i think we
learned last year
that everything went along just fine
without these shows
they're a great consumer place a great
place to go hang out with other gamers
but as far as like announcing things
and and hanging out like you can do that
just as well through marketing online
and i think again the things like the
game awards just continue to
dominate our space and when you have
something that magnetic
you know um why would you put your game
at e3 when you can hold it for
something that's going to get 32 42 i
forget the numbers on the
the last game awards like you know 78
gazillion people
watching you know uh why would you not
just wait for that
exactly that's a good point um i think
one of the important things for us on
our side
is what i'm enjoying seeing is people
realizing that e3 can be more than just
we're covering games and taking the kind
of energy
that and the excitement around it and
refocusing it into something that's
fun for us as people that love video
games but also perhaps is giving back to
the community and useful
and you know we talked about the at the
top of this uh
segment but that's primarily why we do
play for all we
love the idea you know game sports
traffic just shoots through the roof
during the e3 period whether that's
videos or editorial social
more eyes on us than any other time in
the year
and so we want to take that kind of
focus and put it into a good space and
this year that's going to be
to ablegamers so we're going to be
raising money for them make sure you
come make sure you hang out
and we'll make it a good e3 even if the
announcements
aren't as exciting jean-luc as newly
crowned maestro
maestro of live streams how excited are
you
to start putting all this stuff together
and control these live streams from home
uh it's gonna be really exciting this
year because we um
i'm i'm i i love doing uh
behind the scenes live stream stuff like
that that to me is like
when it all comes together and
everyone's just like we're all fire
non-cylinders you guys are doing your
thing on the
uh hosting side you know we're bringing
in great guests uh
everyone's just like it's this big old
team effort and that's
i i it's a lot of work but i love
it it's like there's there's nothing
else like it so i'm i'm very excited
actually to um to do it it it is
it is gonna be a lot of work though
well i have faith in you so uh it's
gonna be exciting
you